good evening from buckingham palace i'm
trevor phillips and welcome to a sky
news royal special on the death of the
queen
coming up in the next hour
tens of thousands of people of all ages
and from all over the country make the
pilgrimage to see the queen lying in
state
[Music]
and here are the live pictures of that
steady stream of people entering the
palace of westminster
the long wait to say goodbye is getting
longer
the queen's queue now stretches almost
five miles and is expected to take over
eight hours to complete
at sandringham while meeting mourners
prince william opens up about how he
felt walking behind the queen's coffin
as it left buckingham palace
[Music]
an occasion like no other
buckingham palace releases more details
of the queen's state funeral including a
two-minute national silence
[Music]
and we take a look at the many ways
britain changed during the elizabethan
age
[Music]
good evening
the queue waiting patiently to say
goodbye to her majesty is now almost
five miles long and still growing
it's almost impossible to imagine this
in any other country
but tonight the global focus is on a
custom we brits have elevated to a high
art the cue
nobody does it better
the public have been given no orders
there is no prescribed etiquette yet in
the midst of the pageantry a popular
ritual is evolving
flowers at the gates
silence in the streets broken only by
ripples of applause
the royal walkabouts go on
with embraces and the quiet exchange of
words between princes and the people
and in westminster hall a stream of
mourners each paying their respects in
their own special way
also tonight we know a bit more about
the queen's state funeral which promises
to be a national occasion the like of
which we have never seen before
we'll take you through all the details
and speak to two people who will be
there
sky's nick martin has been speaking to
people paying their respects
they're queuing around the clock now
around 40 000 people maybe more
it's a queue that's over four miles long
making sure that such a huge number of
people can all get to see the queen
lying in state is proving to be a huge
logistical effort there are now more
than a thousand stewards and volunteers
lining the route to make sure all of
this can be achieved safely
it's a case of eating and drinking on
the move
well i've got a vegetarian sandwich oh
nice what about what have you all been
watching my sandwiches already
as well
and along the route a reminder of big
royal occasions of the past the events
of the last few days of course now part
of that history good to see your eating
we like that
volunteers from st john ambulance
patrolled the route i've helped an
elderly lady who was struggling on her
feet to come along and we gave her some
paracetamol for a bit of pain relief sir
to keep her moving so whatever the
public need to
that first aid from us we're here for it
show your response as you come along
thank you it's the first time experience
in such queue never had it
in past three years in security doing a
lot of events hundreds of events this
queue has been the longest and it's just
keep on coming
you've got to sort of uh sustain
yourself haven't you got to drink you've
got to eat that's it it's kind of a bit
of a mission this isn't it it is a
mission um but there is a light at the
end of the tunnel um and you know you
just know that it's going to be a
magical moment in there so let me have a
look at this
what is this homemade it's a homemade
ham sandwich let's have a look we want
to see
that is a that is a wonderful ham
sandwich that was made at seven o'clock
one of the final legs of this cue moves
down the albert embankment
past the hundreds of thousands of hearts
that adorn the wall in memory of those
who died in the covid pandemic
dara leonard from the red cross has been
offering emotional support to those who
might need it at the core of all of this
is is bereavement and grief
and in some of those conversations
as they're talking
they then disclose about the the death
of a loved one perhaps very recently and
perhaps as you say with the covert wall
down there they're standing looking at
it and it may have been someone that
that has passed away very very recently
and that's when we'll stop and we'll
spend a moment
and there'll be many more moments like
that over the next three days as they
queue to see the queen nick martin sky
news central london
can speak now to the royal historian
anthony selden good evening anthony
good evening trevor
it's been an extremely intense emotional
week uh since uh her majesty passed
is it possible
and we haven't got to the climax which
is monday
what do you think what do you think that
is going to be like
i think it's going to be like nothing
that we've ever seen
in our lifetimes apart from those who
perhaps are over 80 who were 10 at the
time of george the sixth dying the only
thing that touches it will be the death
not of a monarch uh but of winston
churchill
uh who repeatedly comes up as the
top or the favorite uh prime minister
out of the 55
the country has seen
it will be enormous in terms of pomp and
grandeur
and history and uniform and
jewelry and crowns and music
and
[Music]
religion and faith but also the fact
that you've got this gathering outside
of the united nations general assembly
uh every september
the the biggest imaginable gathering
of global leaders and and people of of
uh eminence and power
across the world they all want to beat
the path to westminster abbey on monday
even president biden still
uh the most powerful man uh on earth who
has managed to carve out two days from
his diary to come across
uh for this occasion
i
was really um taken mentally i may say
so by your comparison
with the churchill state funeral which
uh actually i think it's the last actual
state funeral rather than the ceremony
one um
which i was
i'm old enough to remember and i do
remember the extraordinary emotional
intensity i don't know if you recall
there was a moment where one of the
uh pallbearers
a young man
just staggered a little bit and it felt
like the whole nation
took in its breath do you think that
we're going to see
a sort of emotional temperature of that
level
i do
and and more
in a way i i i remember
um that the cranes uh that the
spouting down at the time london was
still much more of a active port and
that was one of those memories and the
train carrying uh the coffin i do i mean
it's different uh churchill um
was so associated
with the second world war on
the hopes of the nation when when this
nation stood up uh and it seemed for
several uh months that germany would
prevail against this country churchill's
will and his speeches
uh managed to give heart to the country
so enormous emotional investment in him
uh but the the pictures we've just seen
of the war uh
some almost a half as many people died
um in during the covert epidemic uh as
during the second brits during the
second world war so
um you know there's a sense that that
she saw this country the queen late
queens through a period of of enormous
uh a national grief and uh uh
bafflement uh when people were
frightened and worried and it was the
queen
more than the prime minister who who
found the words
consoling the nation and significantly
with words echoing back to virulent in
the second world war
we will meet again that she was giving
uh confidence so
people have so many memories of going
back all their lives and their parents
lives and and grandparents lives so this
this woman who who has measured out
family life uh like a clock uh ticking
like a heartbeat uh particularly the
great moments anthony thank you very
much indeed uh i know you will be with
us i think on that occasion um at kanto
we look forward to it but uh we will
anticipate
thank you
skies matthew thompson is near the back
of the queue and we can speak to him now
matthew
let me first ask how are you
i'm happy
you know in a good way i think we're all
well we've been this is day two uh this
is about i think we're eight hours into
it we're certainly feeling i think
yesterday we did something what did we
do something like 22 000 steps on the
old pedometer so we're certainly getting
our exercise in but it's all part of the
experience and actually you've joined us
as you say towards the back of the queue
but it's in this rather nondescript
residential street as you can see
because what's happening is the queue is
essentially
disintegrating i think it's a fair way
to put it isn't it they had everyone
bunched up at the back at southwark park
about maybe 10 minutes from here where
we were a second ago but it's it's going
so quickly we find some people to speak
to that as we've walked with them we've
now walked into the middle of this as i
say rather nondescript residential area
so
the queue is essentially turning into
something more of a long walk uh the
four miles all the way to westminster
because there's no queueing to speak of
it's just people starting at suffolk
park and then walking all the way to
westminster and some people who've just
started that rather long walk are going
to join us now and explain to us why
they've decided to make that long walk
in the middle of the night on a i think
thursday evening i'm losing track of
time thursday evening it's um to honor
our great queen
for everything she's done for us um and
for the world uh we have to remember her
and honor her
and
yeah it's a memorable historic moment
for us as well history but yeah the
reason you've done it so late at night
presumably work commitment absolutely
yeah i think it just felt like um we
could do it with good friends and
get the atmosphere um also appreciate
the people that can do it during the day
so it's also trying to find the right
time for you but it's been absolutely
magical so how long have you been in it
so far may i ask
about an hour i would say about an hour
yes showing back in the park and then
weirdly it's just sort of it's it's
amazing it stops being a queue and
started being a walk yes
i feel like i'm doing the midnight i
would tell people to wear comfortable
shoes if you ever they're joining the
queue on saturday or sunday because you
can't stop so you can't bring seats or
anything i know because it's just moving
the whole time yes you want to tell them
very much
this way have you sent yourselves a
cut-off time and if you're still here if
you're still here at
so as you can see what was a queue is
fast becoming as i said more of a more
of a walk and i suppose that's good news
because if you are thinking about
joining the queue at this late hour the
point is that yes it may be on paper
four miles long but it's still only
about eight hours not the horror stories
we were
anticipating the government at one point
this week said it might be 30 hours in
the queue that's clearly not the case
when actually the queue is
as bare as this so really it's looking
at six or seven hours which is what it
was when we were at the south bank
yesterday which just shows you was about
two miles from here so really on paper
the queue sounds a lot bigger than it
actually is
thank you matthew you you are both the
most hardworking member of our team but
also the most courageous because i see
every time you stop somebody they're
losing their place in the queue but
anyway thank thank you so much
it takes some doing
okay
let's take a look now at the current
length of the queue to get into
westminster hall
we can see that queue is estimated to be
more than four miles long the nearest
landmark is tower bridge
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can watch a live
stream of the queen's lying in state in
full on the sky news website and your
mobile
apps meanwhile in sandringham people who
came to lay flowers were greeted by the
prince and princess of wales
prince william spoke to one mourner and
opened up about his own feelings about
what it was like to walk behind the
queen's coffin
sky's john sparks reports on a
grandson's sorrow
they came with sunflowers and
chrysanthemums and notes of condolence
and carried them down to the entrance of
the sandringham estate a place the royal
family knows well
the queen came here for christmas and
the prince and princess of wales own a
house on the estate and when they
arrived to greet well-wishers well it
may have felt like coming home
they looked at the flowers now
enveloping the front gate
then spoke to dozens of people who
journeyed to north norfolk to see them
the mood was neighborly and prince
william was willing to share
[Music]
you kind of think to yourself i've
prepared for this but i'm not that
prepared he said comparing the
procession of the late queen's coffin to
westminster hall
to his experience at the funeral of his
mother princess diana 25 years ago
it was a startling expression of
openness but it seemed in keeping with
this event for there were other moments
of warmth and emotion
when a schoolgirl called elizabeth
presented the princess of wales with a
toy kate came up with another plan
do you remember what she said to you
she said um
where
she's overwhelmed by it it's just an
incredible experience she's been very
upset about the queen pass and it was
lovely for her to see
the sandringham estate is much like
balmoral a place of peace and some
privacy for the royal family but its
famous chapel makes an annual appearance
queen elizabeth came here to worship on
christmas day
and it won't be the same without her
to not see the queen at three o'clock on
christmas day will just be
whatever for my whole life that's what
i've seen and we've always sat down at
three to do that so it'd be very strange
open and relatable prince william has
revealed something of himself at
sandringham as the royal family
commemorates the past and plans for the
future
john sparks sky news at sandringham
more details are emerging about the
queen's state funeral due to take place
next monday 19th of september
2 000 people including world leaders and
foreign royals will gather inside
westminster abbey for the final four
farewell
buckingham palace says the service at
westminster abbey will be an
extraordinary tribute to her the queen's
remarkable 70-year reign and life of
duty
sky's royal correspondent rhiannon mills
reports on the state funeral
[Applause]
it was an event the queen was personally
involved in planning
on monday we'll see the full spectacle
of her state funeral play out in central
london
rehearsals already taking place timing
everything to precision
at 10 35 on monday morning the bearer
party will begin to move the queen's
coffin from westminster hall to the gun
carriage the king the queen's children
and grandchildren will all walk behind
in a procession to westminster abbey at
11am the funeral service will begin
11 55 the funeral will end with a
two-minute silence
at 12 15 the procession will leave the
abbey making its way through central
london and then at one o'clock the
coffin will be moved from the gun
carriage to the state hearse and driven
to windsor castle
four o'clock in the afternoon the
committal service will be held in saint
george's chapel before at 7 30 in the
evening a private service will take
place where the queen will be buried
alongside the duke of edinburgh in the
king george vi chapel
i think this is bigger than george
at the six bigger than george the first
bigger than victoria so i wait to be
convinced that there will ever have been
a bigger
event and truly
the biggest collection of world leaders
in the 21st century
among the military pageantry the
personal the king and his siblings will
again stage a vigil by her coffin on
friday night this time at westminster
hall
and her grandchildren will join them to
walk in the funeral procession
the queen's own piper will play the
lament at windsor as just like her
husband prince philip this time her
coffin will be lowered into the vault
before privately being buried beside him
for so many decades it was the queen and
prince philip who would welcome
dignitaries to this part of london for
any big events of course this time it's
down to the queen's children and
grandchildren you get the sense also
really want to make sure that everything
we're going to see here on monday also
feels open to everyone and that's why
you'll see representatives from the nhs
in the procession and members of the
queen's charities in the congregation
[Music]
we know they have been comforted by the
public reaction the queen's
daughter-in-law the council of wessex
saying thank you along with her husband
prince edward in manchester
their help now is invaluable to the new
king who having signed off the funeral
plans now has more duties ahead
including a state event at buckingham
palace on sunday hosting all of the
world leaders just 24 hours before he
says his own final farewell to his
beloved mother
rhiannon mills sky news
in central london
let's speak now to someone who's
integral to the queen's funeral
lieutenant commander mike quinn is
captain of the royal navy guard for the
tri-service guard of honor he's in
portsmouth and we can speak to him now
good evening commander quinn
good evening thank you very
thank you very much for for joining us
could you explain for us exactly what
the guard of honors role is here
uh yes so we've actually already been um
involved in part of the parade um as we
are stationed outside the
um in parliament square outside the
gates um where the
the gun carriage uh pulled by king's
trooper horse artillery um went in
yesterday proceeding the lion state
um
and we will conduct royal salutes for
members of the royal family uh the king
uh and the uh and the funeral procession
um and then we will be there uh on
monday
um again in the same position uh
conducting royal salutes as the gun
carriage pulled by the royal navy
uh will move from
westminster hall to westminster abbey
and you will be leading the navy
contingent in that tri-service guards as
i understand it
yes that's correct
can you tell us one of the things that i
think viewers would be interested to
know because we did see
uh
that uh guard yesterday i think some
viewers will be interested to know how
are the
soldiers and sailors and and airmen
selected is it from a particular unit or
is there some uh other way of deciding
who gets that honor
um
there's there's people from uh from a
broad variety of units involved uh for
instance i
uh work within navy command in future
training based in in abbeywood uh we
have personnel who are from
very many different parts of the navy
and we have quite a large number of
personnel
who are really very early stages in
their naval careers um some of them
maybe three or four months out of basic
training and are con currently
um
or fairly recently been conducting
training at hms collingwood and other
training establishments so there really
is a broad variety
of um of sort of units and and
backgrounds to the uh
to
to to the members of both the
uh the guard uh within
the tri-service guard of honor and also
pulling the gun carriage and street
lining
yes i was i was um taken by the fact
that so many of them looked so very
young i understand that some of the
um
service uh
men and women in the guard of honor have
very recently been on active service
abroad
yes absolutely the royal navy is
deployed globally um personnel
involved have have come from ships and
establishments across
um across the navy
and yes we have very many people who've
seen service away uh on ships
uh and submarines with air uh in air
stations um and and all over the world
you could of course uh
practice you can drill um
they
no doubt they would not be selected if
they didn't know
uh
how to uh
manage the actual ceremonials but
i suspect that particularly for the
younger
um
service people there will be an
emotional weight to this how do you how
would you prepare them for that
um yeah i think it's going to be um very
emotional for everybody involved um not
just
the more junior members but
um we
are pretty experienced at conducting
state ceremonial events we've got an
excellent state ceremonial training team
and a combination of um the experience
within uh within those trainers
uh the experience within
uh the senior rates and offices within
the guard and across the
uh the royal navy team involved
um we're doing our best to to look after
all involved
and i i will i could say um 100
everybody is extremely proud to be
supporting
our service of 30 000 plus
on the
on the streets of london um
but
ultimately it's about
practicing the drills making sure that
they're comfortable with that and we are
conducting rehearsals
um we've obviously conducted an early
morning rehearsal um and then the
initial part of the
uh of the of the process uh that that
leads up to the to the funeral uh with
the
the the transition to the to the lying
in state
and so the opportunity to practices
um is a is a is a major one because the
the scale of the parade
um is
it can be sort of quite intimidating but
they've actually they will have seen
seen that and there were people of
course members of the public
uh on the streets uh for the practices
as well
all right come on if i could just ask
you very quickly we've only got a few
seconds um and this is sort of more a
personal question as a former
cadet myself i
i watched the whole of the 38 minutes
uh march from uh to westminster hall and
i didn't see anybody miss a step
did i get it wrong
uh no it was remarkable
yeah absolutely uh yeah it went very
well um
the guard
from all three services um
looked excellent on
parade commander quinn thank you so much
the best of luck for the next few days
and of course for monday
thank you
now from what we do for work how many
children we have where we get our energy
from the at least elizabethan era
spanned 70 years
and during that time we've witnessed
huge changes in population employment
wealth the role of women
ed conway's been looking back at how
elizabeth reign will be remembered
70 years the longest reign of any
british monarch
and it is hard to think of another
period where the country has changed
quite so much culturally socially
economically and one of the best ways of
seeing those changes over time is
through charts
let me give an example over the queen's
reign the uk population grew by 17
million but that rise actually happened
in two stages or ages and these bars
show you population growth so anything
above the line is the population growing
in the 50s and 60s look you can see a
big increase in uk born members of the
population that's those are the black
bars but now i'm going to bring on the
impact of migration look these lighter
purple bars they show people leaving the
country on mass in the 60s and the 70s
that was the brain drain and from the
90s onwards look you can see it is most
of the population growth comes from
immigration that really shows you a
massive shift or another way of looking
at the same story if you look at the
number of children born on average to
each woman the total fertility rate in
1952 it was 2.2 children per woman look
at that line there then that goes up
that's the baby boom there you can see
about three children per woman but today
it's come all the way down to 1.6
children per woman that's the lowest
level on record and well below the
replacement rate that dotted line there
that's the rate at which the population
can sustain its size in the long run
without immigration
what about this ladies for cutting bread
in a hurry when those hungry youngsters
come in for tea the upshot is this
country's complexion has changed as to
have our lives both at home
and in the workplace for men and
particularly for women
consider back in 1952 the female
participation rate women in employment
was just 40 look at that line there but
by the 2020s look at it going up you can
see it'd have risen to over 74 that was
a dramatic change in the workplace
meanwhile the percentage of men in
employment look i'll bring that line on
you can see that line's actually fallen
down from 95
to 84 percent
after 19 years we're free again well
you're glad coal rationing's over yes
why because the customers can have more
and it'll be plenty of work for us
and the nature of jobs has changed too
look this shows you where people work
and you can see in the 1950s about 47
of people worked in primary and
secondary jobs this is getting stuffs
out of the ground or making things with
that stuff by the early 2000s look at
how things have changed it's down to 16
more than 80 percent of us work in that
light purple segment
services these are big shifts but we're
just scratching the surface it's hard to
think of another period where the
country and economy has changed quite so
much
this story is sometimes told as a tale
of decline but i think that's
oversimplification have a look at of all
the measures perhaps the most important
when it comes to how well off we are
this is gdp per capita and have a look
at how this has changed it's measured in
dollars so that we can compare it uh
with across different countries around
the world and the uk look there it is uh
in 1952 compared uh with the rest of the
leading industrialized nations uh the uk
was upper middle of that pack but look
at what happened then all countries got
better off over time look at the bars
they're all going up so everyone's
getting better off but the uk
is getting better off slightly less
quickly than the rest so it fell down on
that particular leaderboard but got
considerably wealthier at the same time
is that decline maybe
but one place you can certainly see
decline is the value of the currency the
pound sterling which of course bore the
queen's image versus a basket of other
currencies the pound has weakened
considerably since 1952 one devaluation
after another from the pound in your
pocket wilson moment of 1967 through to
the imf bailout of 1976 you've got black
wednesday in 1992 the financial crisis
uh in 2008 and of course the eu
referendum each of these seismic moments
pushing the pound gradually weaker
we have been warned but smoke still
comes from many factory chimneys while
from the open fires of houses the evil
paws in even greater volume
but something else happened too it's
easy to forget that as the queen began
her reign this industrial powerhouse was
still pumping out vast quantities of
sulfur and carbon into the skies as it
de-industrialized that began to change
for evidence consider where we got our
power from electricity back in 1952 look
you can see the components of where our
electricity comes from 1952 there's coal
96
of our power came from burning coal but
just look over time about how that has
changed you can see getting on to the
2020s look different colors are coming
along uh look at that black sliced for
one thing coal down to just three
percent by 2021. three percent as you
probably know now the main fuel is gas
that blue slice there 41 of our power
comes from gas but an ever increasing
proportion comes from renewables like
wind and solar that's 13
and rising
the long broad avenue of the mall
towards the admiralty arch the queen's
procession moves slowly onward through
the crowds of cheering people who waited
to show their loyalty and their
affection
her majesty's reign began in a dirtier
more polluted more industrialized
country it ends in one which is
transformed
cleaner
healthier longer lived more diverse and
more equal
where the quality of life may not be the
best in the world but it is much much
improved
on decades gone by
ed conway let's take a look at what is
in store over the coming days now
the queen's lying in state will continue
until the morning of the funeral on
monday
tomorrow the king and queen consort will
travel to cardiff where they'll attend a
prayer service and meet the welsh first
minister
on sunday evening the night before the
funeral king charles will host a
reception for the foreign dignitaries
who are attending that funeral
a minute of silence will also be held
across the uk at eight o'clock in the
evening to honor the queen
then on the morning of monday the 19th
of september the lying in state ends and
the queen's coffin will be taken in
procession to westminster abbey for her
state funeral
world leaders have begun their journey
to britain for the queen's funeral
the australian prime minister anthony
albanese left sydney this afternoon on
his long journey to london at the
request of the queen he will attend the
funeral along with 10 australians who
have been recognized for their
contribution to society
now let's speak now to kim hughes who
was awarded the george cross for his
service in afghanistan where he risks
his life defusing bombs he'll be
attending the uh funeral on monday uh
good evening kim thank you for joining
us um i wonder if you could first
explain
what you did to earn this
extraordinary honor
um i was fortunate to fortunate enough
to be part of a bomb disposal team in
afghanistan um during operation herrick
nine
um
and essentially i was bomb disposal
operator and my task was to to render
safe improvised explosive devices and
fortunately enough on on that day
for the act um
i was recognized but it was also my team
that was recognized for for rendering
safe ieds
when you you save uh fortunately but uh
presumably i mean how many of these
devices would you have had to deal with
over the time you
your tour i mean it varies where you are
um and what you're doing out on the
ground but a bomb disposal operator and
a six month operational tour of duty
certainly in afghanistan um could look
anywhere up to 7080 over 100 ieds
and presumably uh these are not always
done in ideal circumstances where you
yourself are safe and there's no
possibility of enemy fire and all of
that
you know ev every scenario is different
um every bomb disposal operator has
faced um
occasions when they have been under fire
when there have been
circumstances that put both them and
their team in extreme risk but
essentially that was the job that we
were doing
over that period of time
and that's the risks that we that we
took
um
you were
awarded your george cross
by uh the late
uh queen herself what was the experience
like
you know it was an absolutely phenomenal
day the queen was was fantastic i'm
very much well informed about what i had
done what my team had done she knew
elements of my life i really didn't know
that she would um and very very good at
putting people at ease such as such a
nice gentle person
they they say um quite frequently that
when you meet her
she you know the the caricature is she
says to everybody how far you're coming
from but they say that she's as you say
very well informed
about you and about the things that you
do and
we do know that she had a very
close relationship with the armed uh
services did you
feel that you were actually talking to a
commander-in-chief who was more than
just a uniform as it were you know i
said she puts you very much at ease and
the fact that she she knows how to to
talk to you how to engage with you i
mean she essentially was my boss for 23
years um you know she was the sovereign
she was the head of the armed forces and
completely took me off my guard when she
was talking about you know bomb disposal
operators in afghanistan she understood
that there was um
you know we were a limited commodity
over that period um when you say a
limited commodity
what exactly do you mean there wasn't
very many of us um okay it was it and
during the period there were fewer of
you and absolutely it was just it was
you know
you can't just become a bomb disposal
operator overnight there is a lot of
training involved
and and they obviously will not reduce
the standard required to operate in that
environment so
she was very very well up to date with
with current affairs in the armed forces
and
and she spoke very honestly and openly
about it
um a number of the uh
service men and women who've spoken
since last week
have said
the same thing that you've just said
that she was the boss the sense that you
were doing
what you were doing for her in your
particular case i guess on a daily basis
knowing that you might not see the end
of the day
how do you think
that relationship
will feed into your feelings
on monday when you will be present at
that last
ceremony
you know i think everyone has
reflected since um since the queen
passed away and i think during the
during monday um certainly when i'm
going to be at the funeral
i think that i will have my own
reflection of my time spent in the armed
forces and and the times where i've had
the opportunity and the pleasure to
spend time with her majesty the queen
and
um and i think everyone will do that in
their own way
but you and i guess
the team that you have worked with will
presumably
be feeling it very strongly
uh at them
at the moment um what do you think that
that this
relationship between her
and men and women who risks their lives
means
to you and to the nation
i think certainly from an arms forces
perspective when you join the armed
forces whether that's the army the navy
of the air force you you sign the oath
of allegiance to her majesty the queen
um so you have a very personal
immediate bond uh with the queen you're
joining the army because it's something
you believe in is something you want to
do something you're very passionate
about um and i think every
um
man and woman
um in the armed forces will will have
their own view on that and their own
feeling and not just within the armed
forces within everything within our
first responders within our nhs um
you know looking at um
over the period of kobe where the queen
gave the george cross to the nhs um for
the outstanding work that those guys and
girls have done i think across the board
and the entire nation
are feeling it they really are and
everyone will be feeling it differently
we have seen in the last few days of
course
the royal family the queen's
daughter and her sons
in uniform and certainly in two of their
cases that has been more than the
ceremonial two of them
print andrew and prince harry have seen
active service
as did her majesty's
late husband uh the duke of edinburgh so
this is a service
family um
is that do you think
part of what created this close link
with the uniformed services do you think
i think
it's
it certainly helps when you know that
members of the royal family have engaged
in combat and have served their country
um as opposed to someone that's stood in
front of you that essentially hasn't um
and i think that is key when
certainly the younger members of the
armed forces are looking upwards and and
looking at who our leaders are and
looking at the monarchy
and i think that is fundamental
absolutely fundamental and it and what
it does is it just grows strength
of course prince of the new prince of
wales has also been uh
in in service and has flown helicopter
rescue helicopters and um do you think
that that relationship is going to
transfer itself to
the new king and to
his family
i truly do um you know lead by example
um absolutely and
you know the king has pledged his life
um to this country um along with um
the prince of wales you know and i truly
believe that they their family their
children will follow in their footsteps
if you um
i don't know if you had the opportunity
uh to
speak to any member of the royal family
but uh
if you had the opportunity to speak to
king prince of wales uh about
your feelings uh at this moment and
as we go through to to monday
what would you
and your colleagues your comrades want
to say to him
uh about his mother
and your hopes for his reign
i mean
there there is
struggle to say the words to someone
that's lost so much you know as a
country we have lost a queen
the king has lost a mother
you know condolences absolutely but
there's
there's only so much one can say
but
to truly offer him the best of luck in
the future um i i'm very fortunate i
have spent time with the king um
and he is equally a phenomenal person
and and i truly think he will grasp it
with both hands um and we can only offer
him the best of luck
kim hughes thank you very much indeed
and thank you as americans would say
thank you for your service
now the king is the head of state for 14
commonwealth realms but the monarchy's
future role in some of these countries
appears less certain after the queen's
death
last november barbados became a republic
replacing the monarch with a president
as head of state and there's since been
speculating that other caribbean
countries could follow suit
martha kellner reports on a possible
road to a republic
ready
[Applause]
in jamaica sprinting is part of the
national identity the medals on the
world stage a punctuation of true
independence
for these young men their kings and
queens are on the track the monarchy on
the other hand faces an uncertain future
here of course you look forward to
what's coming new and i look forward to
seeing what king charles will do
differently than his mother did do you
think that jamaica should hold a
referendum on becoming a republic i
think there should i think that there's
a trend right now with the bigger
caribbean countries barbados and
trinidad both becoming republics jamaica
is ready for republicism
a visit by the then duke and duchess of
cambridge to jamaica earlier this year
was marked by calls for an apology for
slavery and polls suggest over half of
jamaicans want to break away from the
monarchy
and the country's prime minister is
under pressure to put the choice to the
people afternoon prime minister will you
be holding a referendum on jamaica
becoming a republic sir
the ties to the monarchy particularly in
the capital kingston run deep and for an
older generation which cherishes
tradition the death of the queen marks
the sad end of an era
i am the first one crying on jamaica
because he's just a human being like
everybody and i love her so much in the
the best of jamaica was back in the
of 60s with england that was the best of
jamaica
others believe the days of the monarchy
in the caribbean could be numbered
it was just like okay it's sad
but what's next
um we know what is king charles iii
going to bring to the table historian
alexis is an expert in the country's
colonial past
do people here feel like there's been a
meaningful apology for slavery oh
definitely not um there there's never
been to us an apology yeah you know
there's sort of like
kind of apologies and
roundabout apologies
but not a real sincere
apology for the atrocities of
our former enslaved african ancestors
does that need to come from the royal
family before it needs to come from the
royal family and the british government
both hopefully at the same time
complex challenges in the commonwealth
lie ahead for the new king this jamaica
is evolving and its views are too an
island which may well choose to cut
itself adrift from old institutions
martha kellner sky news kingston jamaica
we're told that king charles is having a
private day of reflection at highgrove
today his
personal home but members of his family
have been out to see tribute to the
queen across the country
the earl and countess of wessex have
been in manchester meeting people who've
come to pay their respects to the queen
they visited manchester central library
to sign the council's books of
condolence
and the countess was seeing seen
emotionally hugging a young boy in the
crowd during the visit as she and prince
edward viewed tributes in the city
tens of thousands of people continue to
come to london making a pilgrimage to
see the queen lying in state
all with their own reasons for doing so
the former prime minister theresa may
and the mayor of london studied khan
were amongst those paying their respects
today
and we've just seen the business
secretary jacob reese mogg in the past
few minutes
at the front of the queue at the palace
of westminster there is airport style
security
the queue then winds its way back
through victoria tower gardens on the
embankment and across lambeth bridge
for those who require it an accessible
route is available starting at tate
britain where timed entry slots are
issued
on the opposite side of the river thames
the queue stretches along the south bank
past the london eye and tate modern
downriver to london bridge
the queue will reach its maximum
permitted length at southwark park in
burmanzi
officials estimate
350 000 people will be able to view the
queen's coffin in westminster hall
now when we look at these huge lines of
people whether on the tv or in person
it's easy to assume that everyone's come
to pay their respects to the queen the
impression is one of a nation almost
completely united in grief
but inevitably it's never that simple
i'm joined now
by stephen rusher who's a professor of
social psychology at st andrews
university
um good evening steve
hello trevor
uh thank you so much for joining us
steve let's let's start with um
what do you think brings people out
for an occasion
like this uh and you know these days
they can watch it in television they can
see it in their their phones they can
hear about it and so on why do they
physically need to be out here
yeah i mean you're quite right it's
quite an ordeal isn't it having to queue
up for several hours eight nine ten
hours um in the cold overnight
and it's easy to assume that everyone
who's there must be a dedicated royalist
um but equally as you say it's actually
much more complicated than that there
are a variety of motives i mean some
people obviously are royalists they
define themselves as british they see
the queen as the embodiment of
britishness and therefore the death of
the queen is quite literally the loss of
a certain part of themselves um and they
feel it deeply they mourn and what's
more as in with any pilgrimage the fact
that it's difficult but it's an ordeal
actually is part of the experience
because what you're doing is you are
affirming your identity by going through
this ritual and the more difficult it is
the more meaningful it is so in a sense
it's not that people are in line despite
the fact it's grueling the fact is
gruelling is part of the meaning of it
now that's something indeed in fact in
fact people were saying to us yesterday
you know she's given 70 years of her
life
i can give a few hours
absolutely now for other people i mean
the monarchy is their sense like a soap
opera it's it's a screen
on which we project and can discuss our
own lives our own issues our own
dilemmas and therefore the death of the
queen the death of a mother invokes the
death of our own mothers of those close
to us and so in many ways people have
grief because they're reminded of very
meaningful moments in their own personal
lives they're not so much mourning for
the queen as mourning through the queen
but then there are very many people who
want to be part of this because it's
history it's a highly significant event
and being part of it gives significance
to them they can say i was there they
can tell other people they were there
there's a little bit of stardust
sprinkled on them
but also and on top of that it confers
upon them a certain amount of of
immortality if you like they're part of
history
they were there when and whenever it
comes up on the television in the future
perhaps even after they're dead they are
part of history um so there are a very
large variety of motives and it's wrong
to assume that everyone who's there is a
royalist and it's wrong to assume that
everybody is there is there in respect
united in grief or whatever and i think
the danger is that we come to false
conclusions about the nature of our
society or even worse we begin to
enforce narrow notions of our society
because if you assume
that the uh the crowd is united uh in uh
monarchism in acceptance of the
institution and if you also believe that
the uh the crowd represents the nation
then you come to the conclusion that
anybody who is not united in grief isn't
really part of the nation is excluded
from the nation and so certain things
begin to be unsavable it's hard to
dissent it's hard to question uh
monacism it's hard to question issues of
colonialism and i think there is a
danger of creating a narrow view of our
society in which a plurality of voices
cannot be heard and certain things
cannot be spoken
i want to come back to that wider point
in a second but but i i saw in an
article that you'd written that you
reflected on the way that this moment
had um
if you like stirred up uh your own
memories of um
relatives passing i'm sure that there's
a
psychologist's uh definition uh word for
for this uh do you think that that is uh
something that's going on across the
country that people are sort of
they're this this is provoked if you
like uh a memory of sorrow for them
which is to do with their own lives well
absolutely i mean so for me yes when
when the queen died it made me think
about when my mother died and i remember
i my mum um lived in london i was coming
down on a train to see her i was told
she was very ill and she died before i
got there and so i felt for harry who
got there too late as well there was an
interesting poll which showed that 44 of
british people shed a tear about the
queen but the assumption was what that
meant was they were all royalists that
they were all shedding a tear because
they were invested in the queen now
things are much more complex than that
and therefore i think we need to be
careful of how we interpret uh the
genuine grief and the genuine sorry that
sorrow that many people had myself
included as indicating if you like a
certain
accepting certain views about society
buying into uh certain notions of
how we should be ruled and so on because
if we do that and i think as i say what
we do is
we begin not just
not to reflect society but to begin to
say that only certain views are
acceptable in society and i think that
would be both a misuse of the evidence
but also something which i don't think
is particularly good uh for a plural
society in an open society
just very briefly steve you've got about
30 seconds one of the things that struck
me is that actually
there's been a sort of evolution of some
what you might call popular rituals the
silence the the applause the flowers and
so on which aren't organized they're
just what people are doing is that
something new for us
no i mean well first of all i think the
important thing about these rituals is
they bring together the personal and the
political they are deeply felt there are
deep and meaningful emotions here but
always rituals commemorations of this
sort are ways of creating a national
identity a way of defining who we are
and what's acceptable in our society and
that's what we're seeing
it's not just history what we're seeing
is the making of history and that's why
it's so fascinating and so important
i would love to talk more about that but
i'm afraid we're out of time steve thank
you so much for that
news at 10 is next
but first let's look back at another
emotional day as the royal family joined
people across the country as they pay
their respects
[Music]
you